hello
i'm nicholas and welcome to the wolfram
tech conference
i'm a math content developer with the
wolfram alpha math group
and i'm also a phd candidate finishing
up at indiana university
wherein my research consists of
molecular dynamics simulations for the
most part
we'll be focusing today amongst the
other 12 talks i'm sure you're attending
on the wolverine language's ability to
facilitate molecular dynamics workflows
so in particular the exemplary case of
nanoparticle self-assembly simulations
i won't dwell on the abstract for too
long as it's just an outline of the talk
i'll pause here momentarily so that if
you're in the web-based version in the
future you can
read this if you so choose just by
pausing the video
i'll take this chance to thank my mentor
vikram shadow and our experimental
collaborators trevor douglas and masaki
uchida all of whom are at indiana
university
for contributing to the uh some of the
content that you'll see today
so we'll start with just an overview of
molecular dynamics
so traditional physics the stuff you
encounter in your classes
employs pen and paper theory in order to
do symbolic calculations exact
calculations
mathematically on solving the dynamics
of a given system
for example you could analytically
predict the motion of say
a massive negatively charged particle on
the left and a smaller positively
charged particle on the right
and you can predict things like the
equilibrium position of the two based on
the forces of attraction and repulsion
for example if there is coulombic
attraction between the charged entities
the steric repulsion due to their finite
size
there would be an equilibrium position
such that for example the
smaller lighter positively charged green
particle would condense on the surface
and come to rest on the surface of the
larger particle
these kind of calculations have the same
setup as simulations would where you
have initial conditions positions
particle properties etc
you have particle interactions energies
forces that are parameterized by the
properties of the particles
and for simulation setup and more
complicated pen and paper problems you
have to take into consideration the
thermodynamic ensemble
and other elements of the thermodynamics
of the problem
this is easy enough to do on pen and
paper for say a two particle system
there's a complicated problem in physics
called the end body problem
and those of you that keep pace with the
wolfram languages developments generally
know about and body simulate
a new function that they've introduced
to numerically integrate such systems
molecular dynamics is a similar
implementation of numerical integration
of systems that are too complicated to
do analytically
on pen and paper so they're analytically
insoluble but you still want to solve
and say something about them
the exemplary case we'll study today
briefly is nanoparticle self-assembly so
if you want to simulate this
why is it important what is it etc
so it's the nanoscale equivalent of
colloidal agglomeration if you've heard
of that essentially
at different length scales particles
stick together
based on the solution conditions
relative to their properties
so like charged particles will have
steric attraction but
electrostatic repulsion and this leads
to
in low salt conditions where the
electrostatic repulsion is strong they
don't assemble
and as they go into lower salt
conditions where the electrostatics
or higher solid conditions excuse me
where the electrostatics is weaker
the uh attraction due to sterics
overwhelms that and the particles stick
together
this is the phenomena or one of the
phenomena that leads to river delta
formation
so fresh water to salt water transitions
changes the electrostatic screening
between like charged particles
this leads to sedimentation and river
delta or the mouth of rivers
their formation we also exploit this
in technological applications such as
paper making cheese making water
treatment where you want to
rid yourself of any impurities and my
collaborators
use this specifically for the purpose of
catalysis or the speeding up of
reactions
wherein if the larger particles which
happen to be hollowed out
viruses the shell of viruses you can put
your own cargo in there that's
enzymes substrates reactants that if the
local concentration is driven up
by the self-assembly process the local
proximity of particles leads to
higher concentrations locally reactions
will speed up by i believe they said 10
to 20 fold
so how would you go about modeling this
process of
particles going from a dilute suspension
to a concentrated
array assembly there are three phases to
any process of molecular dynamic
simulations and that's
pre-processing and setup conception of
the problem
once you've conceived of the problem
accurately communicating that to
your simulation software which is the
central cog here
and then post processing and analysis
and we'll go through each of these
phases individually
and the extent to which in its current
state the wolfen language can contribute
to the process
so pre-processing and setup consists of
a lot of the stuff we've already talked
about specification of initial
conditions particle positions
particle properties such as charge any
steroid propulsion
etc the selection of forces that
represent that steric propulsion
the charge charge interactions etc
specification of any thermodynamics
what temperature you have for example
and specification of this stuff in a
format that the computer can understand
and so this involves the exporting of
data files the exporting of
input scripts that specify the physics
of what will happen during runtime etc
we'll go through each of these
sequentially
so initial conditions is straightforward
we've discussed this you have a box
that you intend to run your simulation
in which is often referred to as a unit
cell
in this unit cell you have say a hundred
thousand particles that you intend to
explicitly
simulate you specify the concentration
by saying the boxes of this size the
number of particles in the simulation is
n and you simulate a certain
concentration which is important to the
experimental collaborators you have
because there are specific
concentrations or packing fractions at
which the phenomenology occurs
and at which they're able to do the
experiments
and once you've done this by say using
random reel to enumerate the particle
positions in your box
using table and if statements to do the
enumeration sequentially such the
particles aren't overlapping too much
so that there aren't numerical issues as
you start your simulation for example if
the particles are overlapping too much
the force will be very high
and the party will shoot out of the box
in the first time step
to avoid small problems like this you
can enumerate particle positions such
that they're not overlapping
and then export that in a file that will
communicate to your molecular dynamics
software
the analysis of the pair potentials so
you've populated your box
you've told it what's going to be in the
simulation but you haven't yet told it
how is it going to
interact you might not have
conceptualized even how are these things
going to interact
during that conceptualization so
the figuring out of what will happen
once you press go in the simulation
you have to know what are my pair
potentials in the simulation
this is where mathematica traditionally
shines as a
you know from day one and that's in
using things like everybody's beloved
manipulate
with a plot in order to
analyze the pair potential the energy of
interaction between different particle
types
for example here i've shown the pair
potential between particles as a
function of their separation distance
varying the parameter sigma which
corresponds to the rigidity of the
particle
so billiard balls bounce off of each
other pretty abruptly when they collide
how abrupt is that uh repulsion
upon collision as a function of r
of course once you have a derivative
once you have a potential function you
can use the derivative and gradient to
calculate the force
involved so that you can plot and
analyze the force
and mathematica shines you know of
course by doing symbolic calculations to
the extent you can for simulation setup
and helping you conceptualize your
problem in that fashion
once you've conceptualized the problem
you've got your data file to communicate
the initial conditions to the simulation
you've got your pair potentials
conceptualized
you need to formalize those in what's
called an input script
for the third-party software whether
it's a self-written c
plus plus code or a third-party software
you simply downloaded to do molecular
dynamics such as lamps or gromacs
you need to communicate what potential
functions you want to use in an input
script
that the computer can understand that
that software can understand
and so mathematica can do the
calculations for
what are typically say thousands or tens
of thousands of simulations that you
need to do
for a given project where you have a
multi-dimensional parameter space
so you have five parameters in your
potential function you need to assess
the
aggregate effect of varying each of
these such that you don't have the
luxury of doing one simulation you have
the
privilege of doing ten thousand and it's
a privilege because mathematica can
automate that process for you
such that it will write input scripts
depending on the parameters
that you specify rather than you having
to slave through those calculations by
hand
so once you've written the input script
or the 10 000 input scripts
for your batch simulation submission
you will have a submission script to
accompany that that specifies say the
number of processors the wall time etc
for example you need to tell the super
computer i want to spend
about two weeks with 128 processors
crunching on this
and it should generate about eight
gigabytes of data
and uh well the warfare language can
help set you up with
a folder hierarchy that has these
infoscripts submission scripts
initial condition data files in them so
that you can submit your 5000 jobs and
then
go work another job or on another
project entirely while those simulations
run for those two weeks
so common functionality in the wolfram
language that will help you in this
process
are the functions like export create
directory copy file
etc because these are essentially
formatted text files
so while a lot of the heavy lifting the
two weeks 128 processors stuff is done
on
the supercomputer it sounds like that
would be where most of your time would
be spent but
typically you can download third party
softwares or you've already written
a software yourself that in the lower
level language for example that does
molecular dynamics such that not a lot
of your development time particularly if
you
just downloaded third party software is
spent in this phase so while the
computational heavy lifting is done here
for example i use a third party software
called lamps and
i submit my batch jobs they're going to
run for two weeks and then i go work for
wolfram during those two weeks
while this process is well the
simulations are running
so often very little development time is
spent on this phase
relative to the elements that the
wolfram language as it is now
can help with more which is pre
preprocessing and post post-processing
so moving on to post-processing this is
where you stand to really expedite your
workflow
so the unclear haze associated with the
analytical insolubility of the problem
uh many body problems for example
this carries through to the analysis so
you don't know exactly what variables
you're solving for
you don't know exactly what's going to
happen because you can't solve for the
variables even if you knew what they are
and so you need to compensate by doing a
lot of exploratory data analysis
and typically in my experience in a
molecular dynamics project
exploratory data analysis gets published
at about a 10
rate such that you do a lot of
exploratory data analysis
oh this doesn't indicate an underlying
kinetic or thermodynamic mechanism
and so we're going to throw that
analysis out and we're going to proceed
with a different type of analysis
you have to be fast in doing this
otherwise you will drown in the
amount of exploratory data analysis you
need to do
and the wolfram language is uniquely
poised to expedite that workflow
so the different types of
post-processing you'll do are
visualizations simple snapshots as you
see here
quantitative analysis to get at the
kinetic and thermodynamic mechanisms
quantitatively
like you would do in a traditional
physics problem and quantitative
analysis such that you understand
exactly what is going on physically in
the simulation
for example structural inferences etc
the
spatial statistics for example
so visualization is obviously useful you
know mathematic excuse me the wolfram
language is great at that
it uh is incredibly useful to see what's
happening before you go to analyze it
you know a lot of people are visual
learners you know those those kind of
cues are important in
not only understanding what happened in
the simulation but in corroborating
the observations that can be made
experimentally so here are
visualizations associated with the
projects that i worked on for the
nanoparticle self-assembly
where you can see the plot label here
varies from
left to right increasing salt
concentrations so as you titrate salt
you see a pretty drastic variation in
the propensity for self-assembly where
in some ionic strength conditions salt
conditions
you see extensive self-assembly and then
some you see no self-assembly at all
there's the
electrostatic screening effects we were
discussing briefly and similarly
you have the same left to right
transition in the bottom right figure
where
without a microscope without anything
you can see the optical density shift
from an opaque milky white when there's
an assembly condition like
salt concentration such as assembly
occurs to a translucent color
where there is no light scattering
because there is no assembly
and similar similarly with microscopy
techniques you can visualize
this assembly process where the array
has formed in
the bottom half of the panel in the
bottom left figure
and so corroborating visualizations
between
simulations and between experiments is
the initial thing and sometimes for
biochemists example
for example the only thing that people
want to see right
this you don't have the luxury of
looking at say even just four
simulations like i showed you
there those were cherry picked from
often
dozens hundreds thousands of simulations
and so the ability of the wolfram
language to instead of opening up a
visualization software scrolling to the
end of your time series
the last snapshot of the video and
taking a screenshot
and spending your entire life doing that
with every condition for those thousands
of simulations
a simple command where if you've written
a function
that will visualize your simulation
mapped onto the simulation directories
that you found using for example the
function find
find file which will find output
directories as well
if you simply map this visualization
function onto your simulation
directories and use multi-column
it will produce a nice panel where
you've titrated salt if you can see the
very small text in the
plot label this is a 10 millimolar salt
condition 25 millimolar salt condition
50 and so it goes left to right bottom
top to bottom and so the ability to
scroll through these expeditiously
rather than
say taking snapshots and putting them in
a powerpoint is incredibly valuable and
will triple the amount of projects you
can work on per unit time if you do it
properly
and so moving on to quantitative
analysis
how do you enhance this picture
with quantitative data we'll
brush through this quickly such that you
have the snapshots that you have on the
bottom left
you have the same titration and salt on
the x-axis for both quantitative plots
you see here
the top left is an experimental
assessment of the optical density
so how opaque is that solution where it
peaks for assembly conditions and goes
down for non-assembly conditions
in some forms of light scattering the
radius of gyration is what determines
that
we've used a wfr that i've created to
give an estimate of the radius of
gyration of these particles
the uh assemblies rather and you can see
that while it's not a one-to-one
correspondence we wouldn't expect it to
be in this case
there are the same behaviors where you
have a domain of assembly and
domains of non-assembly
this ability to take a time average with
say a wolfram function repository
function
expedite your workflow orders of
magnitude over what you would come to
think c plus plus could do right if you
did all of this coding in c
plus we'll get to a more quantitative
example later
but it will slow you down considerably
one other example of neat quantitative
analysis that you can do
with these kind of systems is on the
left you have a cannonball stacking
it's called an fcc or hcp lattice
i believe hcp here but don't quote me on
that
the two are very similar they're close
packed sphere rigidly spherical lattices
and a cannonball sagging is what you
would see if you walked into a war
memorial you walked in onto a pirate
ship
etc from the visualization in the center
you can kind of think
perhaps that's a similar stacking and if
you look at the radial distribution
function also known as a pair
correlation function
you can see that indeed the grid lines
here we won't get into what this is for
the purpose of time
but the grid lines here correspond to
where you would expect peaks to be
were the nanoscopic lattice
the same as what we see for cannonball
stackings on
human length scales and indeed you see
peaks at those
positions such that it is indeed a canon
ball stacking
despite the huge change in physical
mechanism from gravitational
forces to electrostatic forces the
underlying mathematics of
stacked rigid spheres and the close
packing nature of those lattices
is the same and so this can be done by
simply using
this resource function for the time
being i believe spatial statistics
functionality is being added such that
you might find this as a kernel function
that other developers have worked on
which would be great such that similarly
to visualization you have a function
that you've written
that you then map onto your simulation
directories there's a little bit extra
because you have to take time average of
your data
which you import using a file stream or
something
but that's the bare bones structure of
how you would conduct this kind of
analysis
such that you can show interesting
phenomenology beyond just looking at uh
simulation visualizations
so the wolfram language can enhance your
workflow drastically
by providing pre-processing and setup
functionality to allow you to
expeditiously submit thousands of
simulations after you conceptualize the
problem
and it can help you do post-processing
and analysis expeditiously such that you
don't have to do it in a lower level
language like c plus plus
there are community development aspects
to this
where if you'd like to not only enhance
your own workflow you'd like to enhance
other people's workflow
you can write wolfram function
repository editions as i've done here
where if you click one of these
hyperlinks when you download the
notebook
later for example if you so choose you
can go and find
the source code for this such that other
people can use it as i had highlighted
in the previous slide
without writing any code on their own
and that's truly the power of higher
level languages like the wolfram
language
particularly now that it's more
community driven with the function
repository
so the function repository offers you
the ability to contribute to wolverine
language development
and and if if you're a uh
a self-promoting type to promote your
work as a citation
in the metadata of the function
repository edition
so i've cited my own paper here where i
use this functionality
uh upon contributing it to the uh
the repository so
if we go to a summary i want to
highlight
more clearly in post-processing analysis
the third phase here highlighted in the
uh gear diagram
the extent to which you can speed up
your workflow by working a high-level
language
so i've written and other people more
seasoned
than me i've had three or four years in
c plus
other people that i've talked to who
have had you know probably about 10
years of c
plus experiment experience we wrote a
function to do the radial distribution
function about 400 lines it didn't have
error handling it wasn't terribly robust
but it did the job
that took about 400 lines it was fast
because it was c plus
the comparable functionality
enroll from language takes about four
lines so instead of writing 400 lines
for several days
you write four lines in an hour or two
it's incredibly efficient
and troubleshooting to look at four
lines if there's a mathematical problem
and find it immediately
in fact i had to use my wolfram language
functionality and the clarity i had
there
to troubleshoot why the c plus plus and
the warfare language
instantiation didn't match because the c
plus plus had so much
code fog that i couldn't see the
mathematical mistake existed at first
a robust contribution such that has
error handling it won't crash your
kernel it doesn't
accept bad inputs that would crash your
kernel etc
it's about 70 lines in the wolfram
language so still
less more than a factor of two lower
than the c
plus requirement additionally this auto
compiles to c
for speed such that you can
in 70 lines produce something that has
the speed benefits of a low-level
language without having to write the
low-level language code yourself
this is reminiscent of this four lines
to 70 lines of
being able to do two to two to a hundred
times more
lines of code in a lower level language
is reminiscent of a uh i think a blog
post i saw recently our marketing thing
for wolfram saying that
you can get something interesting less
than five lines and that's absolutely
true
and so in an academic environment where
seven percent of phds are seeking
academic positions because of the
job market the enhancement of your
workflow allows you to
publish rather than perish you know
publish not perish
by working on multiple projects at the
same time rather than getting
overwhelmed with
trying to work in a lower level language
entirely and the auto compilation
bridges the efficiency gap between
the two the low level languages in the
wolfram language
this the future of the wolfram language
doing molecular dynamic system
simulations directly such that we can
eliminate that central cog
of a third-party software lies in this
ability to self-compile
so self-compilation is already used in a
variety of applications to greatly speed
up with language code
hopefully someday it will be used to run
simulations themselves in the wolfram
language such that you don't even have
the need to communicate with a
third-party software at all
and hpc or super computer support for
wolfen language already exists
so with that i'm happy to take questions
i think i've probably gone over a little
bit on the time
feel free to email me at nbrunk
wolfram.com
or set up a time to meet during the tech
conference
in off hours thank you